this game is so [ __ ] weird
humphs - mm-hmm welcome to Nobi Nobi boy
this game this game can I get it this
game this game my god are you ready the
game isn't asking me please let's start
with the boy quiz guess the controls
I'll just guess the controls question
one okay
how do you make boy I you know what life
trigger what a [ __ ] tutorial just
guess the controls that's brilliant so
in this game you're a giant sperm it's
great it's fantastic holy [ __ ] we can
fly what is this game I've never been
this scared in my life
no no don't go back I'm scared I'm not
even gonna ask I'm not even gonna ask
we're gonna grow big bros can eat that
yes
poop it right out no big deal no big
deal at all we need to find tiny objects
to eat there you go poop it out we're
gonna become huge gross eat it poop it
out it's just like life this game is a
metaphor give me yo ass they're all
running away scared as [ __ ]
come on yeah
holy [ __ ] that was a good poop
that was a really a holy [ __ ] it's not
how I eat I'm just flying now cool
that's that's great so I remember I
bought this game for so many years ago
when the PlayStation 3 first came out
and I just thought I like what oh my god
I was just so amazed how [ __ ] weird
this game was but it's really nice holy
[ __ ] my ass is so big
oh he's riding me holy [ __ ]
Wow the bunny is sitting on my ass I
don't know what is going on I think I
might have taken some drugs this morning
I'm not sure we're contained
we're like an anaconda literally Oh God
sometimes you have to poop though sorry
guys no free letters instead of bird
carrying a bunch of balls cool hi bird
ball can I eat you man this game is
amazing seriously I feel like with
really horrific music like horror music
this game would be completely different
I'm scared
[ __ ] is coming back oh god my [ __ ]
got charged come back here no [ __ ]
get back on earth I got a trophy for
that [ __ ] oh god oh god okay don't you
just hate when your ass is so big that
it falls off the planet hashtag
relatable ass please come back to me
I promise I'll be good to you uh asses
back no no goddamn hey um I'm like a
Chinese dragon nice oh god oh god it's
like a cannon of [ __ ] it keeps happening
oh my god how much did I have in there
we're gonna make a game about a guy that
stretches out any poops [ __ ] out yep the
kids will love it what the [ __ ] is that
banana doing that CD banana [ __ ]
that's right I'll eat you what are you
gonna write now [ __ ] is that a shark
that a shark and the moon
it's so cute oh there's the king can we
eat him can we eat the moon King oh god
it's a lion
I'm sorry Lion King but you have to
become my [ __ ] I'm the new ruler of the
Moon Kingdom that's right [ __ ] be
come and enjoy the cloud my ass I hope
it's soft and nice for you know
hemorrhoids let's finish this with an
explosion blast go
all right this Gail is amazing I'm so
glad I revisit it and gave it a second
chance only seven years later I hope you
bros enjoyed it as well and maybe you
had the same experience with it and now
your eyes have opened or maybe the
opposite I don't know but I had a lot of
fun playing it and I hope you brothers
enjoy checking it out with me this is a
really [ __ ] squeaky chair gross thank
you so much for watching I will see you
in the next video as always stay awesome
breasts won't tell me a joke
you will so cool Wow oh you [ __ ] ass
dick [ __ ] you [ __ ] you hope you [ __ ]
die